après un feuilleton à rebondissements de
plus deux trois ans le royaume uni a
définitivement quitté l'union européenne
au grand dam des ressortissants
européens établis sur son sol pour ces
français qui travaillaient à londres
l'inquiétude qui planaient autour de ce
divorce semble s'être dissipée dans la
vie quotidienne ça va rien changer juste
le fait que si je continuais à vivre ici
à travailler ici qui a fermé voyage
france à retourner en france
eh bien il faut que je fasse mes papiers
je dû faire des démarches
administratives pour régulariser ma
situation pour pouvoir juste prouver que
je suis résidente ici au royaume uni
depuis plus de cinq ans et que je suis
autorisé à résiste à rester sur le
territoire mais c'est la seule chose ça
m'a pris cinq minutes j'avais demandé ma
carte de résidente permanente et l'année
dernière j'ai passé les tests et je suis
venu donc citoyens britanniques
je me suis je me sens autant anglaises
françaises européennes et pour moi
c'était important de pouvoir rester dans
ce pays
au delà des démarches administratives
nécessaires pour demeurer sur le sol
britannique
pas grand chose ne devrait changer pour
ces français travaillant au royaume-uni
et ceux qui souhaiteraient s'y rendre
pour charles henri gallois la peur qui
planait sur le break site n'était pas
justifiée sur ce sujet là comme sur tant
d'autres
on était en plein projet de la peur
pourquoi on a fait croire aux français
ou du berger un aux européens qui vit au
royaume uni qu'ils aient quasiment
expulsés du royaume uni la réalité c'est
quoi ses yeux à peu près de 7 millions
de demandes d'européens genre au
royaume-uni et on a eu seulement 6
refusé donc c'est absolument ridicule et
le royaume-uni d'ailleurs la diva donner
des titres de séjour à moins qu'un des
problèmes individuels à tous les
français tous les européens qui vit au
royaume uni pour les 300000 expatriés
français presque donc aucune conséquence
dans leur quotidien pour ce premier jour
hors de l'union européenne
même si certains s'inquiètent plutôt de
l'angleterre de demain une fois que les
accords auront été établis avec
bruxelles
[Musique]